i first met him when he was taking intro
to data science at columbia he um
he's actually written a very popular
text analysis package he
really wants you to know that despite
writing this great software and being a
data scientist
at large companies he has never taken a
computer science class
so please welcome to the stage adam
uh thank you so much jared for having me
um let me start by
um as you can tell i'm british so
a couple of apologies to start the first
is the majority of the material i'm
covering here is not
um in our techniques are
available in our something you could do
in r but most of the code is actually in
python
the second one is that my background
game is nowhere near as strong as rob's
you can see a little slice of downtown
brooklyn out of my window but rob's
room setting was absolutely top notch if
you've been following the room rater
twitter account which is looking at
people's
backgrounds in online interviews the
rooms that their interviews are in
i think rob is easily at a nine or a ten
you should really try to get a tv
interview
in that room if you haven't done so
already because it's great all right
so i'm here to talk to you um about
adaptive experimentation
which is um three things it's the name
of the team
that i'm on at facebook which is part of
core data science where i'm a research
scientist
it's the name of a family of techniques
um and it's also the name of a package
called
axe which is an open source package
which my team
and which is used to apply some of these
techniques
so let me go ahead and um set
up the sorts of problems that we're
dealing with here so we're talking about
bayesian modeling
and optimization and we're talking about
acts uh the adaptive experimentation
platform
um so briefly the the problem setting
here
is it's an optimization problem where
we're trying to optimize a function
and there are a couple of important
characteristics about this function
the first one is that the form of the
function is not known
right it's a black box function it's not
a function where we can compute
gradients it's not a function where we
know anything about the relationship
between the inputs that function and the
output
and the other thing about this function
is that it's computationally expensive
to evaluate
which is to say you could imagine this
being the case in two of the canonical
applications of these techniques which
are
hyper parameter optimization for machine
learning applications where retraining
the whole model
is expensive with a different set of
hyper parameters
or you could think of an experimentation
context where
the model is a relationship between some
continuous
or discrete treatment variables and some
outcomes where in order to measure the
outcomes you have to run an experiment
and see something happen in the world
and so in both of those cases you want
to minimize the number of times you do
this evaluation
you want to sample as few points as
possible in order to optimize
this again unknown function so the
applications here
as i said hyperparameter optimization
for machine learning problems
experimentation in particular where we
have multiple continuous treatments
so you can think of this as you know
continuous variables which determines
something about
the um the treatment which which the
experiment is
putting in place another another case
um you know like a cute application of
this is you can think of this
being used for physical experiments as
well right not just um
abstract online computer science type
things but
in manufacturing so um there's a nice uh
reporter about this from google about
using these kind of techniques to
manufacture cookies to figure out the
optimal cookie recipe
and the idea there is that a cookie
recipe is just an
experiment with a bunch of continuous
parameters right the amount of butter
the amount of flour
the amount of chocolate chips and the
time that you
uh bake the thing for all continuous
parameters and for some combination of
values of these things you're going to
have the optimal cookie
all right um so
the solution that to this category
problems that you come across
in uh bayesian optimization is uh
in order to optimize this unknown
function we're actually going to
optimize a different function
so the function we're trying to optimize
is the target function but because we
can't compute gradients on that
or speculate about the values of that
function for
unknown inputs what we're going to do is
fit a surrogate model
this is a function which aims to
approximate that target function
and so you can you can think that we've
evaluated the target function for some
observed points right we've baked some
cookies and seen how good the cookie is
um and so we fit a model to those points
we've already observed but this model
allows us to extrapolate to other points
which we haven't observed
and importantly because of the bayesian
approach
this function also allows us to quantify
uncertainty
so you can imagine this surrogate model
is going to try to pass
through the points we've already
observed and it's going to have low
uncertainty there because we have
actually observed those points
but for other points um it's it's going
to extrapolate
it's going to make a prediction and it's
also going to tell us you know if this
point is very far away from the points
we've already observed
then there's probably it's probably
highly uncertain
uh we make a point prediction but
there's a range that that prediction can
fall in
and then we use this surrogate model to
select new points to evaluate based on
the acquisition function
an acquisition function is just based on
you know all of the the predictions we
can make from the surrogate model
um which is the most useful next point
and
the difference between acquisition
functions is how you parameterize
um most useful right you could think
that the naive thing to do is we just
select the points which
our model predicts would be the maximum
but then what do you do next right um so
and then we iterate and i'll get into a
little bit more detail of like real
world
acquisition functions in a bit um and
then we iterate this process
so we observe some more evaluations the
target function we fit the surrogate
model and we keep going
um until we get to some optimal point
okay
um so just to describe the setup
graphically what you can see here is a
representation of a very simple bayesian
optimization problem
where we have one continuous parameter
that we're trying to set
which is on the x-axis and ranges
between 0 and 12
and we have the the
output the value which we're trying to
optimize on the y-axis
so we've observed in this case five
points um
we have the axes for the evaluation the
the point estimates um we have some sort
of confidence interval
interval that we've observed that
depends on the noisiness of the process
um we have in gray the unobserved true
function
which we're trying to optimize and then
the blue is this gaussian process the
surrogate model which we fit it and as i
said
it passes through the five points um but
it also gives us this
uh this band around it which quantifies
the uncertainty
and you can see that in the regions
where we haven't observed any points the
uncertainty is high
okay so what's next next we calculate
the acquisition function
in this case it's something like
expected improvement and the idea behind
expected improvement
is that we're going to try to
um to find uh
the point where based on
that the current maximum that we've
observed for the function
and our expectation that if we sample
this next point uh the the
the optimal value of the true function
is going to be the highest
and you can see that here that the
expected improvement is actually pretty
high
in this uncertain region right um
and and in fact the optimal value marked
by the purple line um
sorry the the the
the expected improvement is higher in
this uncertain region because even
though
um we haven't observed it our our
gaussian process says there could be
some pretty high values here but
we don't know what they are okay
um so as we go through this uh iterative
process
you'll see that uh um
we observe an additional point here
based on expected improvement that
redefines our acquisition function then
we observe another point and
all throughout this we're reducing the
uncertainty across the board
um and then we get to the
the point where we think you know it's
more or less optimal and we can stop
um the same thing also applies in uh i
should say
uh two-dimensional uh cases obviously
and
in fact relatively high dimensional
problems can be
solved in this context um another thing
that's worth noting is that
the selection of the initial points is
kind of an interesting problem too you
could imagine doing it with a grid
search like trying to cover the space of
parameters
but also you could imagine doing it with
some sort of init
thrifty initial design and the idea here
is that instead of doing a grid
we want to choose some sort of space
filling function
so again remember trying to minimize the
number of points that we have to
actually evaluate
a space filling function to try to cover
all of the space
and give us some idea of what's going on
without having quite so many points as a
grid
okay so now let me talk about acts um
the way this works is that axe sits
between
um either people trying to manually
optimize these process
or processes or could be integrated into
a larger system and it goes through this
experimentation loop
um where it can control experimentation
in
outside systems this could be a b tests
it could be a machine learning system it
could be benchmarking
it could be an ml system it also
supports human in the loop optimization
where you have to go in and intervene in
order to evaluate the function
and it'll give you all sorts of nice
features including the
the bayesian modeling and also some
visualizations of real data
which allow you to figure out trade-offs
between multiple objectives if that's
your sort of problem
and also look at the the
these um surrogate models to see what
your space
the space of your function looks like
all right so now let me switch to the
demo
um
okay that seems to be working
all right so the idea here um
this uh is based on an example for
tuning a convolutional neural net
uh which is uh available on the x.dev
website as a tutorial if you want to
work on that as well
so the first couple of cells here are
just doing some setup
uh we're going to be training this on
mnist um
we're we're choosing a small percentage
of the actual data so
this demo can run in real time while i'm
talking
um so we do some setup to load the right
libraries
we have these train validation and test
loader sets
i should say that underlying this ax is
doing the
high parameter tuning part the actual
cnn is implemented in pi torch
um okay so what's the first thing we
need to do
in order to be able to optimize this
function
and this function again is going to be
the function from the hyper parameters
of a convolutional neural network to the
accuracy of that cnn on this set of
mnist
so the first thing we need to do is
define the function we're going to
evaluate so let's do that
so we're going to call it train evaluate
because it both trains a model and
evaluates the model and this is going to
take in a parameterization
parameterization and
the idea here is this is a dictionary
which specifies the values of the
parameters that go into this function
and within this function we'll create a
cnn
we will then uh train that cnn and some
of this is using
uh helper functions which are defined
for this tutorial but you can do the
same thing
using uh raw pi torch so we'll train the
cnn
uh we'll train on the training data
and we'll specify parameters
okay and a couple of
counting things we have to do
okay so this would result in a neural
network trained on the training set
and then we need to return the output
value for this function right so what
we're going to do is we're going to use
this evaluate function
which will give us the accuracy for the
network
on the validation set
here
type again type and device
equals device okay so we've defined this
function
so let's just evaluate it once to see
what see what it does
um so we'll set a manual seed for pi
torch
for reproducibility and we'll call train
evaluate and here we're going to use the
default
uh values that pi torch would use for
these two high parameters for training
the cnn
so we're going to use um we're going to
use a learning rate of 0.001
and we're going to set momentum to zero
okay so i don't have to actually
okay for it there you go okay so this
takes a little minute to run
you can see that we're achieving 10
accuracy
uh on a validation set it's not
particularly great okay so now let's go
through the actual
um optimization part of this so
we're going to uh set the seed again and
now we're going to use the actual ax
function
so this is a function which will return
a few different things um
i'll define those in a moment but let's
just call optimize
so we're going to optimize and we have
to specify what parameters we're trying
to optimize
um and here again this is just going to
be
the learning rate and the momentum we
have to give act
a little bit of information about this
so the first one is a learning rate it's
called lr
the type it's going to be a range
parameter that is to say it's a
continuous variable which can go between
two bounds and we have to specify those
bounds as well so this is
part of the search space right the the
area within which it's going to search
and that's a reasonable range i'm also
going to specify this as a log scale
parameter
so that we're sampling from a log scale
rather than treating it as a linear one
okay so that's the learning rate
parameter we're also going to specify
the momentum
and this is also a range parameter it's
not log scale
and by construction this one ranges
between
zero and one okay
so that's the parameters we also have to
specify the actual function
evaluation function is train evaluate
and uh a name
for the objective just so we keep track
of that
not that it's uh the label
okay so this optimize function returns a
few different things
it returns the best parameters
it returns the values it returns uh
experiment
and the actual model itself in case you
want to look at that later
all right so i've set this running and
um just in a
uh it'll take a couple of uh minutes to
run let me just describe this output
here
so what this is telling us is that we're
using bayesian optimization yes
we're using a particular generation
strategy which is a combination of
uh generating those initial points that
we're going to look at and we're using a
syllable function for this which is one
of these random space filling functions
and then we're using gpei which is as i
said gaussian process
with expected improvement as the
acquisition function for the subsequent
trials
and by default we're running 20 trials
um
and on you know on a
the actual full mnist data set this
takes on my machine
maybe five minutes to run i cut this
down for the purposes of the
presentation so that i have
time which i'm getting perilously close
to
and uh that should be complete okay
so let's see what parameters we came up
with
so we ended up with a learning rate that
was smaller initial one and a momentum
that's uh somewhere around 0.4
and we can also look at the values that
are returned by this
so here the values of the values of the
function we try to optimize and we've
achieved an accuracy
of 0.7 and this is telling us the
the variance of that measure that could
be useful if you have multiple outcomes
all right so let me wrap up
um so hopefully that's giving you a bit
of an idea of the sorts of problems you
can use bayesian optimization to try to
solve
and if you want to learn more about acts
contact me through hop in come to
acts.dev
have a look at the tutorials and figure
out whether there is an application
which you think might be useful for
any of the problems that you're facing
thank you very much adam
live coding a neural network at a
conference
is brave that was pretty awesome
thank you very much for doing that